- I always said this for many, many years,
the fans cannot fight for you.
And one thing I know
I can do, I can fight.
I'm a chess player, I play chess.
Every move is calculated.
I get my credit about
what I do in the ring,
but I don't get my credit
about what I do on the outside.
- Hello Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn from one of
the greatest boxers of all
time, Floyd Mayweather,
and my take on his top 10
rules of success, volume two.
Rule number seven is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around
it so other people can
be inspired by it as
well, and if you leave it
within the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(upbeat music)
- You have to have a certain
charisma about yourself,
a certain look about yourself.
That Pay-per-view attraction,
that Pay-per-view look.
I know, because I was a young
kid and I had that same look.
Certain fighters, Oscar De
La Hoya, he had that look,
Sugar Ray Leonard had the look,
Mike Tyson had the look.
Certain fighters have that
look and that charisma
about them to become Pay-per-view stars.
And if anybody know about who can become
a Pay-per-view star, you're talking to
the king of Pay-per-view.
You have to realize, we did so
many record breaking numbers,
we don't no longer call it Pay-per-view,
we call it May-per-view.
- It reminds me of Ali and Frazier,
not the fight, but the pregame.
- [Floyd] The build-up, yes.
- The pregame.
And I'm watching you, I know you,
you're my friend.
I'm watching you hold your composure.
It's a few times you
wanted to sock that mother.
And I know you, and I know you
was being very professional
saying I'm the boss, I must
conduct myself in a boss manner
in front of my employee, 'cause
nigga you is my employee.
Is that the attitude that you had?
- I mean, I just felt like, you know,
taking the chance of when he
touched me a couple times,
when he said some--
- Hello.
- Very disrespectful remarks a few times.
He said a few things
that pushed my buttons,
but just with experience
I'm not fixin' to...
In the long run it'll cost
us hundreds of millions
that we all could be
putting in our account
if we do it the smart way so I say,
you know what, I'm a hold
out, wait 'til August 26th.
- [Snoop Dogg] Righteous.
- And do it when it counts.
I'm not going to do it
when it don't count.
I never focus on anything but
the guy that's in front of me
because when it comes down to it,
I always said this for many, many years,
the fans cannot fight
for you and one thing
I know I can do, I can fight.
So, the fans when they shout, scream,
I don't worry about nothing.
I just keep my composure
and stick to the game plan.
Constantly keep coming
ahead, coming ahead.
Pushing him, pushing him,
pushing him back, pushing him back.
When he first come out for the
first 20 seconds of the round
when he go down, when
he go back to his corner
and he sit down, I said when he come out,
he going to come out for
30 seconds and fight hard.
And then he going to
break and once he break,
that's when I'm going
to shoot the hard shot
to the body, hit him
with a hard shot up top
and keep pushing him back,
keep pushing him back.
Remember, I told you guys
weight doesn't win fights.
Fighting wins fights.
And then when I said
talking doesn't win fights,
fighting wins fights.
Meaning that when we was on
the stage for the weigh in,
I don't have to do no more talking.
We fighting tomorrow
so I did enough talking
on our tour, basically.
So everybody said, oh, Mayweather,
you was talking on the tour.
Okay, I did a lot of talking on the tour,
but now it's time to fight.
We 24 hours away from the
biggest fight in the world.
The biggest combat fight in the world.
There's no need to talk anymore.
It's a kid, a kid named Taylor.
He has cancer.
Kid said, my only wish before I die
is to meet Floyd Mayweather.
And that's not the only kid
that has said that that is his wish.
His or her wish.
But this little kid named Taylor,
and he came to the boxing
gym and waited for me.
I got here on time and when I seen him,
it brought tears to my
eyes because he reminded me
of my oldest son, when
my oldest son was young.
And this kid is only 10 years old.
So, we took a picture after he was here.
He seen me box, he seen me train.
We talked, he asked me so many questions.
But, we took a picture.
I wanted to post it on social media
and I couldn't post it
'cause I couldn't find the words to say.
Every day I think about
this child, every day.
So yesterday when I woke up,
before I came to the boxing gym,
I said, you know what I want to do today?
I want to call Taylor.
I want to spend time with this kid.
So, I got in touch with his dad.
I said, I want to go to GameStop.
Went to GameStop, took the kid in there,
I said, get everything you want to get.
Life if priceless, life is priceless.
And your health is your wealth.
So a lot of times, they say Floyd,
won't you stick around boxing,
you can make this and you can
make that, you can make this.
Two years off, I could
have made a ton of money.
But remember, your health is your wealth.
- And to the fans that are still upset
with what went on in the
Pacquio fight, you say what?
- The fans have to be mad at Pacquio.
They can't be mad at me, I done my job.
I never said I was a checkers player.
I'm a chess player, I play chess.
Every move is calculated.
But the fans should
have thought about that
when I was running through
everybody at one particular time.
So now I'm just older and wiser.
I'm older and wiser, it's like fine wine.
I get better with time.
Everybody know in this room
that's watched me fight,
I could've easily
out-boxed Conor McGregor,
counter-punched him all night.
That's not what I wanted to do.
I wanted to go out with a bang.
I told you guys I would
come straight ahead.
I feel like I owed that to the
fans for the Pacquio fight.
Even though I don't owe anybody nothing,
I put the pressure on
myself and did it myself,
and that was a goal of mine.
I told you guys that this
fight wouldn't go the distance.
- It's over 300, not 200 million.
It's over 300 million dollars for tonight.
- Yes.
- 350.
- 350, about 350 million.
- So I broke my record.
- So you broke your record.
- I want to say this,
with ShowTime and CBS,
with the deal they gave me,
(mumbles)
Three fights with the Canelo, the Pacquio,
and this fight with Conor McGregor,
I think 750.
I've made over a billion
dollars in my career,
but just those three fights, 750.
From CBS and ShowTime.
- So, but your name is money
and obviously that validates it.
Are you sure--
- I'm through.
- That if somebody else can't
come with a nine figure.
- Stop, just stop. No, stop.
- I'm just asking, another nine figure?
- Can you let me retire
and be happy, please?
- I've tried three times.
- Just please, please.
- Okay, okay you're done, you're done.
I'm not going to bother it again.
- Tell them, tell them.
- He's done, he's done
ladies and, he's done.
It's over, it's over,
he's not fighting again.
- You don't want nobody from MMA or boxing
calling me out no more, tell them.
- Don't call him out
anymore, he's retired.
- Thank you.
- He's retired, going to be happy.
- A man that has never
been in the boxing ring
is in the ring with the best ever,
that's what you describe
yourself as being.
- I don't describe myself.
We must realize, men lie,
women lie, numbers don't lie,
- 49-0.
- Not just 49-0.
- We've got time, I'm
listening, I'm listening.
- Mayweather that's done
broke every record in boxing.
When we get to talk about highest gate,
even when they said Mayweather's
fight didn't sell out.
Well, you know, when it do sell out,
I think I reached somewhere like,
the live gate it reached
like 80-something million for this fight.
Already, we already at
60-something million,
for those they saying that Mayweather
is not doing numbers anymore.
Far as taking the less punishment,
I took less punishment than any fighter.
Not just best defense,
let's talk about offense.
The most accurate fighter of all time.
On the outside the ring,
it's not just about
being on the inside of the ring.
I already conquered that.
I'm even smarter on the outside.
I have to be a genius to even
make a fight like this happen.
So what does that say about me
for making this fight happen?
- It says that you're a
brilliant business man,
not just a great boxer.
- And that's what I always spoke about,
that's what I always spoke about.
I get my credit about
what I do in the ring,
but I don't get my credit
about what I do on the outside.
- Where did you get that business sense,
because you've surpassed
everybody in boxing,
in sports, in everything in general.
I'm watching you, it's like
you bigger than the NFL franchise.
- Just my team, me believing.
I'm going to be honest,
I have a team also,
but my team don't get in there
and go to war like I go to war,
but they go to war on the outside.
My team go to war.
I'm very, very tough on my team.
I want my team to be the best
that they can be on the outside.
But as far as on the
outside, you know Al Haymon--
- That's the OG right there.
- That's OG, a legend.
A legend.
A very shrewd businessman.
Leonard Ellerbe, Master's
degree in business.
So, you know when you surround yourself
with people like this,
just being around certain individuals.
Like, even being around Don
King, being around Bob Arum,
being around just different
people that's been
in the game a long time
and you know, by being their buddies.
You know, every time I got
around by being their buddies
I was more like, it's cool
to come over to your house
but I need a house like this.
It's cool to ride on your yacht,
but I need a yacht like this.
It's cool to ride on your jet,
but I want a jet like this.
And I said, no, I don't
want to ride on yours.
You show me how to get it.
You can't be my friend if you
can't show me how to get it,
'cause once they show me how to get it,
then I can install it in my children,
then it goes, it trickles down.
- Bloodline, it's a bloodline thing.
- Yes, so it's about wealth.
You know, I'm no longer rich, I'm wealthy.
Last thing about my career.
I never want, as far as making weight,
when you asked me about
Cervantes tanked making weight.
He's young, but when I was young,
I think I would have
made those same mistakes
if I didn't have my father in my life.
You know, just being a coach that
was extremely hard on me.
I think that if he didn't
discipline me in boxing,
I don't even know how my
career would have played out.
I didn't want to slack, and I didn't want
to seem irresponsible or not disciplined,
so that's why I always sacrificed.
You got to sacrifice
something to get something.
So that's why I've always made sacrifices
to get to a certain level
and to get to the pinnacle,
you got to make sacrifices
and that's what I did.
- Why is the money so important?
Why do you always come
back to the dollars?
People want to know, I mean,
you obviously have a
fascination, you've earned a lot.
You show it all the time,
you talk about it a lot.
Why does it always come to money?
- Why not?
I mean everything you got on costs money.
Everything you do costs money.
You can't take your
wife on a date for free.
- Is that how you measure your success?
- No.
Me, I'm loyal and honest.
And I'm a good person, and
I call a spade a spade.
Money don't make me, I make money.
And without money, I'd be the same person.
I've so many fights for free.
- You're getting emotional now.
- No, not at all.
No, I'm thinking.
You know I'm always thinking.
how can I get better,
how can our company grow,
how can I continue to teach
people around me how to fish
and I don't want to fish for them.
We teach you how to become entrepreneurs.
And if we can't, we want you to be
the best that you can be
if you're under the banner.
(lighthearted music)
Great dance partner to dance with.
Conor McGregor, you a hell of a champion
and to the country of
Ireland, we love you guys.
(applause)
- Big round of applause for
two classy, classy gentlemen.
(applause)
- But I give him a hat's off,
Fair play to him.
He's a composed man.
You can give him no more respect.
He took the shots early,
and he took shots early.
He cracked them with the left hand
and I saw him in a bit
of panic but he stayed
very very clam, that's just
his years of experience.
- He's a tough competitor
and he still have
a long career ahead of him.
- Does he have a career in boxing?
- We got to get his conditioning
a little bit better.
- On that a little bit,
and explain what you liked
about the boxing business
and what you prefer
about the MMA business.
- The check is alright.
The check is not bad.
(laughs)
Very good, but look...
(mumbling)
Great job.
- Floyd, congratulations, terrific career.
- Great work.
- Good job, thank you, good job.
- Ladies and gentlemen, to the podium,
I'd like to call up The
Notorious One, Conor McGregor.
(applause)
- What's up everybody?
He had to change his style of fair play.
And he did, he adjusted,
he changed his style.
He put the hands up, more forward.
He's composed.
He's not that fast,
he's not that powerful,
but boy is he composed.
Hands up toward your forehead, dipped in,
forehead on the chest and decided
to fight that kind of fight.
I didn't anticipate that, three
game changes in the fight.
That's what a true champion does.
Much respect, you came with it.
You know what I mean?
I got to give respect to that.
(applause)
It was a hell of a fight.
- Was he better than you had expected?
- He's a lot better than I thought he was.
He used different angles,
he was a tough competitor.
But I was the better man tonight.
- He was making me throw when
he was patient with his shots.
I got to give him nothing
but respect though.
Fair play, great career that he's had.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
DreamChasers Motivation asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in our future top 10, please check out
the link down in the description below
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Cyrus Webb.
Cyrus thank you do much for picking up
a copy of my book Your
One Word and posting
that awesome picture to
your audience on Twitter,
and also the five-star
review you left on Amazon.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support, man,
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book.
Thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- [Man] Floyd, just a follow up on Conor,
there's a lot of concern
coming into this fight
that the rules were going to be followed,
and it was a little bit
rough at times in there,
there were some warnings.
How did you feel about the way
Conor conducted himself
in the ring tonight?
- I let the referee do his job.
You know, I let the referee do his job.
I'm not here to bash the referee,
but you guys know what was going on.
A lot of rapid punching, a lot.
Things happen but you live and you learn.
The referee is a hell of a referee,
Conor McGregor is a hell of a fighter.
I'm not here to bash anyone.
I just went out there
to do my job tonight.
- As you've been away from the game
and you reflect on your life
and your career right now.
- Yes.
- Where are you?
Just looking at the life
of Floyd Mayweather.
- Just looking at my life?
I don't think most people
could handle being in my shoes.
Yo, yo.
- You good, you're good.
- I mean, as of right now I don't think.
no one could handle my situation.
- [Interviewer] Why not?
- They just can't.
- [Interviewer] What's your
situation that can't be handled?
- I'm saying, they feel
like it's pressure on me.
Like I said, they tried to
defeat me in many different ways.
They try to bring up the tax thing,
they try to bring up he's been locked up,
he's arrogant, he's unappreciative.
I mean, years and years and
years they've been trying
their best to defeat me, mentally.
I can't be defeated.
I'm a strong individual.
Nothing can throw me off.
Nothing can throw me off key.
I'm always focused on what I got to do.
- And that's going to
be the case August 26th?
- August 26th going to
be real interesting.
And I'm not backing up.
Remember I told you that.
- [Interviewer] You're not backing up?
- I'm not backing up.
I hustled a hustler, I go for the jugular.
Couldn't work not job, I
probably cuss out the customer.
(laughter)
I'll smuggle the smuggler,
I'm the first from the grind.
I'm a bad boy, always knew I would shine.
I bang with the bangers,
I flame with the flamers.
You know what my name is,
I'm more famous than Amos.
I hate all the haters, cut
the lights off in Vegas.
We making this money, but
this money don't make us.
I'm taking my time, ain't
got time for the taking.
I went ham in the streets
just to bring home the bacon.